the supreme court marks the 49th
anniversary of the landmark case roe vs
wade this weekend rallies and protests
are expected both for and against
abortion rights in the coming days and
this all comes as the supreme court
considers reversing row which would
allow individual states to pass their
own abortion laws bloomberg news
reporter kelsey butler has been covering
the issue and joins us now to discuss
what's at stake kelsey great to speak
with you for context here the courts
deciding on a mississippi case and they
are indicating that they're likely to
side with the state in that case if they
do that roe gets undone walk me through
what happens next in that scenario what
does abortion access look like across
the u.s if and and when scotus does make
that decision
right so what will happen um is that
abortion access will even more than it
does now come down to what state you
live in right now we know that there are
restrictions and a lack of providers in
many places
but what will happen is that about half
the states in the country
already have laws in place that if roe
is undone would essentially make an
abortion impossibility in those states
idaho south dakota are two places where
there are trigger laws that would
immediately go into effect banning
nearly all abortions as well
can you walk me through i know there was
a series of these trigger laws that were
created in a bunch of these states can
you walk me through sort of what led to
that
seeming trend uh especially in these
southern states was it an anticipation
of the supreme court undoing row
um well
merely pretty much since uh rowe uh
the road decision became the law of the
land there have been um
groups that oppose abortion that have
been kind of working to chip away at it
on the state and local level and what
we're seeing is that a lot of those
really big things that impact people on
a real uh day-to-day level happen at the
local level and
that's really what it comes down to if
there isn't an abortion provider um
anywhere close to you and you have to
drive you know 300 miles away that's a
real um you know impactful thing and
that's been happening for some time yeah
of course of course thank you so much
for explaining that and i know from your
reporting that the majority of abortions
are now acquired via an abortion pill
if roe is overturned and states have
these trigger laws that go into effect
right away
could other states like new york start
to
funnel abortion pills to
people in other states who might need
them
uh well a really big restriction on the
abortion pill was just lifted that
allows people to get it by mail but
again things really come down to what
state you live in so there are already
about 19 states where there are
restrictions to the abortion pill things
like requiring you to
requiring a person to take it in the
presence of a physician for example so
that again still requires travel
potentially time off work um and some
type of coordination got it okay i know
that one argument we heard from lawyers
in the mississippi case is that women
have more equality now they're paid
better so the hardship of motherhood is
a little bit less than when roe was
first passed 49 years ago talk to me
about the the
reality of that argument what is the
economic situation for mothers in the
u.s right now
um so i do want to talk about the fact
that you know abortion does
abortion and the access to abortion does
have an economic and a financial impact
um a woman that wants an abortion and
isn't able to get one is four times more
likely to live um in poverty and um you
know that cost the abortion restrictions
that are already in place cost state
economies over a hundred billion dollars
every year already um you know we also
see in the u.s that the u.s is a country
with a high maternal mortality rate
compared to other countries like canada
or france
so
in addition to the financial impact
there is also a very real real life
impact um
as well yeah and can you talk to me
about the demographics who is most
impacted by abortion restrictions in the
u.s
so what it really comes down to is
workers that are in jobs where it's not
as easy to necessarily go and get time
off to potentially travel somewhere
additionally people that don't have the
financial means to travel out of their
state if their state is
has
very strict abortion laws you're not
going to be able to do that if you don't
have the money and those in rural areas
where abortion providers are uh few and
far between already yeah sure and how
does the u.s compare to you know other
countries other other peer countries on
the issue of abortion access and
reproductive health access
sure so this actually came up in the
oral arguments in the mississippi case
and uh lawyers did point out that the
u.s
right now compared to other peer
countries you know does allow abortions
up to viability so that's you know
anywhere from 20 to 24 weeks countries
like great britain and germany allow
that and um in the last 50 years
or i'm sorry in the last 25 years about
50 countries have uh liberalized their
abortion laws um you know countries like
thailand mexico uh argentina for example
have moved forward on abortion rights uh
very few countries have moved backwards
to make abortion more difficult got it
and
like we were speaking about earlier
kelsey there are so many obstacles uh in
the u.s including paid family leave
another thing that you've reported on is
maternal mortality rates can you explain
that to me and how the u.s compares with
with pure countries on on how they're
doing with maternal mortality rates
absolutely so uh the us
maternal mortality rate is more than
double a lot of other countries you know
i'm just thinking canada france
the uk
and what happens is that women of color
are at you know
even greater risk a black or indigenous
woman in the u.s is three times more
likely to die of a pregnancy-related
cause than a white woman
and in certain places like new york city
for example those statistics are even
worse so you stack that on top of a lack
of parental leave and you really see
large
large slots of pregnant people that are
facing some really big challenges during
that time in their lives sure and kelsey
just taking kind of a bigger broader
step back
what does your reporting tell you about
what the decision to overturn roe v wade
would do to women's rights in the u.s
and what what would that kind of look
like moving forward i know you spoke
with women from now for example what did
they say about that
so yeah that i've written about that and
how the us is going you know was really
a leader on women's rights when roe
became the law of the land almost 50
years ago
what that's going to do is really kind
of put the country in a place where
is it really a great place for women and
that's the question that a lot of
women's rights activists are asking
right now right right of course final
question for you kelsey as we look into
2022 knowing that this could potentially
be the final anniversary of
roe v wade as as law of the land
what do you think that people
misunderstand most about the importance
of abortion access and abortion care in
the u.s based on your reporting
so i think
the thing that comes across when i talk
to experts and they really emphasize is
that you know it's a very um it's an
issue that has broader ramifications um
it impacts yes one person but it also
impacts families economies and the
future trajectory of their uh
these people's lives right of course of
course and like you said earlier the
people who uh need help most already in
most cases kelsey thank you so much for
joining us and giving us that context
really appreciate it that was bloomberg
news's kelsey butler there's still a lot
for america to wait and see what happens
surrounding roe v wade so we're going to
continue to report on that for you right
here with quick take i'm madison mills
in new york stay with us for more